so my husband casually dropped today
that he met this chick on Bumble that's
only in town for a week so we all know
what that means so I sent him a text
like babe live your best life if this
thing goes all night you want to go back
to her Airbnb you want to stay so that
you can hit it in the morning again live
your best life babe I got it here at
home why did I do it because I'm such a
good polyamorous wife first of all
um but also because you put that karma
in the bank and then y'all girls gonna
cash it out later so there we go and
that's that's really it isn't it that's
the whole uh shebang if you'll pardon
the expression why do you have a
polyamorous relationship what's the
point of an of a quote-unquote open
marriage which is a contradiction in
terms well because it's entirely
self-serving you know that's the point
this is mutually agreed upon adultery
one adulterous spouse tolerates the
adultery of the other spouse so that she
has a license to behave the same way
it's also emotional blackmail at the
same time